brought to you by The Witcher Wild Hunt
available May 19th
Poland's maybe a little country but it
has a booming game to have seen now
that's obviously great for Poland but
it's also pretty good for me and you who
get to play games like the wood shop
since The Witcher 3 is sponsoring this
episode we figured we take a look at
some other awesome games that have come
from this little European nation one
pretty awesome game that you may not
know comes from Poland is the vanishing
of Ethan Carter
aside from grabbing a spot in my top 5
favorite games of last year the
vanishing of Ethan Carter charmed
audiences by attempting something really
different
polish studio the astronauts took a
murder mystery narrative and turned its
players into the ultimate detective a
detective that doesn't have to shoot
anyone gameplay involved exploring the
massive and beautiful world finding
clues working out the chronological
order of events and ultimately
unraveling the larger darker mystery of
Red Creek Valley within their extensive
game ography polish studio Techland have
made a couple of pretty popular
household names zombie games those being
dying light and Dead Island dying light
and Dead Island are massive staples in
the recent resurgence of zombie games
the first-person
open-world Dead Island was praised for
its atmosphere and despite its faults
and bugs the game gathered a pretty
dedicated cult following dying light
took that formula further and impressed
gamers with its freerunning mechanics
co-op play and creepy dangerous
open-world complete with day/night cycle
11 bit Studios released anomaly warzone
earth in 2011
again which took a unique spin on
realtime strategy games warzone earth
plays like a reversed tower defense game
and as fast paced tactical mechanics
drew a cult following who stuck with it
through its steep learning curve we
nominated it for best strategy game in
2011 and
won a bunch of awards for its iOS
version including the incredibly
prestigious Apple design award this war
of mine almost went unnoticed by a lot
of people last year probably because it
came out in the busy November release
period but it had a really interesting
take on war storytelling the survival
game was also developed and produced by
11-bit studios it set itself apart from
most other games in the genre by
focusing on the civilian experience of
war as opposed to that of the soldiers
the PC strategy game lets the player
control multiple characters taking
shelter in an abandoned house who
require constant help hunger and mood
level management to stay alive during
the night the player needs to scavenge
dangerous nearby areas for materials and
supplies while in the day they'll have
to craft tools and make sure survivors
arrested sane and healthy by making food
bartering with strangers and upgrading
the shelter Polish studio people can fly
kicked off their resume with the
painkiller series but these days they're
probably better known for the
over-the-top FPS Bulletstorm and Gears
of War judgments these two games were
hugely successful four people can fly
who are now known as epic games Poland
2011's Bulletstorm impressed gamers by
having a dark sense of humor and proving
it was happy to get a little weird by
enabling creative and often ridiculous
kills by introducing an energy whip
weapon and letting you kick everything
Gears of War has a reputation that needs
little explanation its most recent
installment judgment did a pretty good
job of impressing gamers who were
already invested in the series by
continuing with its tradition of tight
combat and a story that drove deeper
into the gears law following Damon Baird
and Coltrane let me know down in the
comments if you were surprised by the
origin of any of those titles and which
one is your favorite I'll catch you
again next week